dasha her mum vera and dad are about to
try and complete a more than 10 000
kilometer journey this is what they're
fleeing from they say these videos show
their hometown nikolayev in ukraine
now via moldova and romania they've
arrived at the mexican border town of
tijuana
their hope to get across that line and
into the united states
how has this been for you dasha it was
hot
we were sleeping in the car by three
nights because we're staying in a queue
to
leave ukraine
i imagine that because you're the
english speaker you're having to do a
lot of the
yes the the logistics
dash is 14
but all her effort could still be for
nothing there have been reports of
ukrainian refugees being turned away
they're pulled aside
and then let in
we saw several other ukrainian families
similarly ushered forward it seems here
the blue passports become the ticket
through
the red one of russia is proving less
effective a small camp of dissidents
from that country was stuck outside the
gate asking for asylum too after
opposing the war
mike is also half ukrainian and is
frightened of being conscripted to fight
against a country where he is family 24
february
my country
attack
ukraine
evolve reunion
my brother is used to leave
this
city
it's shock it sucks for me
for the russians here europe isn't an
option flights and countries are closed
to them but not mexico where they can
get in via a tourist visa then travel up
to tijuana there are far more of them
than ukrainians here
sleeping rough outside the entry point
to try to pressure officials to let them
in
so far the only word has been weight
the united states has a public health
order in place because of the pandemic
which says that it can reject just about
anyone who is asking for asylum apart
from unaccompanied children and what
that means in practice at entry points
like this one is that it can really pick
and choose who it lets in and it seems
that at the moment that's ukrainians yes
dissident russians like the ones in the
camp not so much and the mexicans and
central americans that say they've been
living in unofficial conflict zones for
years now with next to no hope of
getting into the us
we found this family of 17 watching as
the ukrainians went in ahead of them
their green passports carry little
weight
the grandad told me they fled southwest
mexico after he was kidnapped and beaten
the rest of the family threatened that
was two months ago
you feel bad because you can see that
they give priority to another country
how am i going to feel but what can we
do that's going to be a constant
question for the desperate in countries
neighbouring the united states as they
wait and others go first big
organization in ukraine but at least
exhausted ukrainians like dacha and bera
are finding a safe haven they called us
from her godfather's house in los
angeles
we was waiting this moment for a long
time but we were happy that everything
is
it's like
this
john holman al jazeera tijuana